Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
Thank you for joining us today. Today, we
are continuing our exploration of cloud native and
advanced event driven architectures using any new forward
future facing software that we can get our
hands on, and today is no exception.
Now today, we're gonna take a look at
adding a new feature to Guidepad, and that
is a project that we have covered once
or twice on the channel before.
The secret about today's episode is is that
we are joined by both members of the
founding team.
Hello, Matthew and Reggie. How's it going? Hello.
Good. Thanks for having me. Great. Thanks for
having us. Really happy to be here. Absolutely.
My pleasure.
I think I've made my feelings about Guidepad
very clear to people over many sessions now,
but let's get back to that in a
minute. First things first. Can you both just
say hello? Tell us a little bit about
you and what you're up to. Yeah, Rich.
I'll defer to you. You go first, and
and I'll Sure. Pick it up a second.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm the cofounder and CEO of
Guidepad,
and my background is in consulting.
Did a little a a lot of work
at cloud
about ten years ago.
Really got interested in distributed systems, built a
platform,
sold some software to the government, and
met Matt about four or five years ago.
We got started building software, and we built
Guidepad as our own internal developer team, tool.
And, it's kinda taken us over the last
few years, and we're really excited about what
we built and where we're going.
We are a unified developer platform,
so we could cut across a few of
the main pieces of building, you know, software
such as DevOps,
AIML ops, data integration, and workflow automation.
And I'll let Matt introduce himself, and we'll
go from there.
Cool. Yeah. Thanks. So I'm Matt, CTO,
cofounder.
Yeah. Like Reggie said, we met, you know,
four or five years ago. My background is
a little different. I was in academia for
about seven years, did biotech for a bit,
bounced around in there, fell out into normal
tech,
and then, you know, met Reggie and the
rest is sort of history. So, yeah, Guidepad
is
sort of our attempt to
crystallize
all of our, like, experiences over our years,
our joint, you know, combined years, like building
these distributed systems.
You know, when building these sorts of systems,
it's it's hard to, like, standardize things. It's
hard to make things repeatable. It's hard to
make things observable.
And so Guidepad sort of takes all of
our learnings about how to do those things
well, bundles it up into a a platform,
and then tries to, you know, make it
available to other folks.
Awesome.
Alright. You said something that I hadn't heard
before, but made a lot of sense when
you said a unified developer platform.
So maybe the both of you can dive
into that a little bit and just help
the audience understand, like, what can Guidepad deliver
and what problem is it solving?
Sure. Yeah. So,
you know, when you think about building distributed
systems today, you're you're probably talking about, you
know, half a dozen tools off the bat.
Something for your your CICD,
something for your your back end, something for
your
logging, your issues tracking,
data engineering,
right,
managing your infrastructure.
So Guidepad has
the building blocks to put all of those
things into one tool.
And then whether you wanna do stuff at
in a user interface or at the command
line or in like an interactive coding session,
Guidepad has ways into all of those things
so that you can do what you need
to do without having to jump between a
bunch of different tools,
essentially.
But it's also, like, not that opinionated that
you couldn't sort of integrate Guidepad with stuff
that you're already using. So,
you know, if you have a preferred workflow
management system,
but you wanna use Guidepad for, like, generating
endpoints or managing like your units of work
that go into that that pipeline system, you
can do that.
If you don't have a workflow management system
but you do have maybe a CICD thing,
you can use Guidepad's work plan system to
automate, you know, the tasks that you're doing.
And sort of, like, as you get more
comfortable with the system, you can, you know,
you can put its tentacles out into more
of what you're you're doing. Yep.
Nice. Anything to add there, Roger?
No. I think I think he hit the
the nail on the head. You know, a
lot of our customers right now have come
have come to us. Some of the use
cases that we've seen, a lot of our
clients, larger enterprises are looking for, like, a
unified, like, cloud control plane. You know, most
most customers we talk to are hybrid in
nature. So they have workloads across AWS, Azure,
Google Cloud, and some still have workloads on
premise. And so having one tool that can
help
manage all of that, manage and control everything.
And then data engineering and workflow automation,
has has been another big thing for us.
So, you know, as as you'll see, once
once Matt goes into the demo, we start
diving into the tool, you know, very little
code that has to be written. We we
do things dynamically at Rawkode.
Yeah.
So we have covered this before, and the
very little code to be written really highlights
one of the key strengths of Guidepad. And
something that you promote on the website as
well is that you can build a platform
or software as data.
But for anyone that hasn't seen anything previously,
maybe we can go into that in a
little bit of detail just for a few
minutes before we go into the actual live
portion of this. But what does that mean?
How do people build their new pieces of
software and their platforms using Guidepad as that
substrate?
Sure. Yeah. So
it really you know, when we think about
like a platform as as data. Right? We're
we're talking about moving,
building a system from
sort of a
a build the system sort of thing where
you go in and you write code for
each of the pieces. This is sort of
like the old sort of infrastructure as code
thing. Right?
Where you have a bunch of files, they're
spread out. Maybe maybe you're good at organizing
them and they're in one repository. More likely
they're not in one repository. They're in many
repositories.
They all have distinct, you know, like ownership
and maybe, you know, maybe the folks that
own those things don't get along all the
time.
So there's a lot of there's a lot
of friction, right, when you're stuck sort of
in file land.
And so what we try to do with
Guidepad is move you out of file land
into data land
where you can be more collaborative.
It means that you're rather than writing, you
know,
scripts that orchestrate
your your software
and your applications,
you are writing specs, so configuration.
And then Guidepad takes those specs and produces
things for you. Right? Whether it's the the
commands that need to go out and deploy
a web server in your Kubernetes cluster,
or Guidepad needs to manage
an ingress for you or Guidepad needs to
create an s three bucket for you. Those
things become configuration
problems rather than sort of code problems.
And when you're in data,
you can sort of move the paradigm to
I'm not building a system, I'm programming a
system.
So things become more repeatable, things become more
observable.
You can write then the scripts that you're
writing are actually orchestrating
all of the components of your system that
are stored within some data store storage engine.
And we'll we'll talk about this more when
we go into the platform, but Guidepad is
sort of data storage agnostic.
It has what we call the type system,
which is a layer on top of what
you would consider to be like an ORM.
But that ORM, you know, allows us to
plug into, you know, different data storage things
whether that's a database, Postgres, you know, MongoDB.
You can do things you can actually store
parts of your system
in files if you want to. You can
have a data store that's an s three
bucket. You can have a data store that's
an API.
So there's a lot of flexibility as far
as like where
you store the parts of your system. And
what that what that allows you to do
is to tailor that storage to the performance
requirements of each sort of piece of your
system. So it's like,
this particular data structure works the best in
Postgres. So let's put it there. Well, this
part, we actually don't really care about the
structured stuff so much. We wanna be able
to store a bunch of disparate,
you know, polymorphic types of things. Let's put
that in MongoDB. It doesn't care so much
about the schema. There's less overhead about maintaining
stuff.
Yeah. I'm rambling now. So I'm gonna stop
doing that. And if you have a question,
have it answer it.
No. It's not rambling. You're, you know, you're
just sharing how the system works. I think
a lot of us be solidified for people
as they see us explore the platform, add
new features, and kinda show how to work
with it.
Maybe that should be a good time then
for you to discuss or share what is
our plan for today. What are we going
to do?
Let me should I share my screen now?
I can do that. Yeah. Go for talk
through.
Great.
Let me actually move the the call window
over
so that I'm not sharing all of us.
Here we go.
Great.
Okay. Perfect. So is it can you see
it?
Yep.
Awesome.
So I guess maybe before we get into
what we're gonna do today, I can spend
just a few moments talking about,
like, the high level concepts within the system.
That might help folks as we sort of
move through into the actual implementation.
So this is the
Guidepad UI.
This is the instance that I created just
for this,
you know, this livestream.
So every Guidepad installation we call an instance.
Typically, it's, you know, it's one per
customer.
They all get their own domain name.
You can we can host them or they
can be hosted on premise. We have an
installer that sort of stands one of these
up in like a couple minutes.
And with this installation, you get a what
we call an environment.
An environment is a bundle of resources.
So draw a logical box around like an
AWS account or Kubernetes cluster
or an Azure account. And that's an environment.
Right? Environments can be big or small. Just
depends on where you wanna draw the boundaries
around them. You can see in this particular
instance, we only have two right now. We
have,
a Kubernetes cluster here,
which is what is sort of hosting all
the infrastructure for this. And then we have
a build excuse me. We have a build
environment, and that uses the
packer from from Terraform.
We'll we'll actually use that as part of
part of the demo. So
environments are bundles of resources.
Into those environments, we put services.
Right? And so services
are the things that provide capabilities for your
they're actual, like, parts of your system. Right?
And so in this particular instance, we have
the things that come along with every Guidepad
installation. So we have the user interface, which
is what we're looking at now.
We have two things to manage work plans,
so the automation piece here.
We have an open search data store, which
is used to store the logs and the
events that go on in Guidepad. I think
No, not issues. Issues are stored in the
main system. Anyway, I'll get to that in
a second. And then we have
this thing, which basically just manages ECR credentials
so that this cluster can access all the
images that it needs. And then this one
here is the generative API, and not generative
in the Gen AI sense, but generative in
the I read a bunch of operation specifications
and make endpoints.
And it does that in all the frameworks
that we support, and that right now that
is REST, GraphQL,
and
I think we do it over message exchange.
Yeah. We have a it's not deployed in
this instance, but we could deploy wrapped in
queue server, and then that server would accept,
API requests
and give the results and all that good
stuff. So I talked about operations,
and we'll also use operations in our,
in the feature we're building today. So operations
are
portable, repeatable units of work that have predefined,
inputs and outputs, and a handler. So you
can think of them sort of as, portable
functions.
And those you know, these operations,
they're they're data records,
and then you can sort of summon them
up at will and and use them.
But the Guidepad API uses those definitions to
create the endpoints that I've I just I
just mentioned.
And the nice thing about operations is that
they can execute in any environment that you've
already set up for your instance. So for
this particular demonstration,
the operations that I run can either run
locally on the machine that I'm looking at
here, or they can run-in that Kubernetes cluster
that was in the environments list. And I'll
show you I'll show you an example of
that, like, as we as we get into
things.
Okay. So, we have environments. We have services.
How do you manage the services in the
environments? Well, we do that through what we
call state plans. Right? And so I'll go
into a state plan and sort of show
you how that works.
So state plans are the actual commands that
are used to get the service in that
particular state in a given environment.
And we'll take a look at this deployed
plan for for Kubernetes.
This is sort of the default one. Every
service when you create a service definition, if
it doesn't have state plans defined within that
definition,
it just uses the default ones, this is
one of them. You can see it's just
one one little node.
All of the state plans are DAGs, right,
just directly cyclic graphs.
They're made out of phases, so every node
is a phase. That's this box here.
And then inside a phase, you have, serially
ordered stages.
Right? So this one only has one stage,
I could add more, below it. And those
would op those would execute top to bottom
when this phase executes.
So if I click into the stage,
you can see there's actual commands in here.
I apologize. I have to, like, move stuff
around. I'm on my tiny laptop screen.
But yeah. So these are the actual commands.
You can see it runs,
a series of Ansible steps
when it executes to create a volume claim,
service definition,
and then a deployment.
They're parameterized.
You can see in here that we're doing
templating. Right? So this can pull information
from what we call the context
of the state plan's execution, and that context
includes
things like the service that you're deploying, the
environment it's being deployed into,
any requirements
for the service. And I'll talk about requirements
more later,
because they're they're a very flexible way of
specifying either
what a particular thing needs to to execute,
or individual pieces of data that a part
of the system needs, like at runtime, to
to do the thing.
So yeah. So, you know, you use state
plans, to put services into particular states.
If I go to the, environments,
over here,
you can see that I've been deploying things.
And I think I mentioned this, I might
not have, but the the UI is a
couple steps behind the the core capabilities of
the system and we're on a develop branch.
So, any visual bugs, you'll just have to
forgive me for where we are aware of
them. But I wanted to give you the
latest and greatest, so that's why this is
showing not a number.
Anyway,
Yeah. So you can see that,
these are these were all deployed earlier.
And so they went from transitioning to deployed,
transitioning to deployed, to deployed them a couple
times.
And then these are all the services that
are in the system.
Like, it shows you the ones that, like,
you've deployed into this environment and then these
are all of the ones that haven't you
sort of been haven't interacted with this environment
yet, but they could.
Yeah. Okay. So environments, services, state plans, state
machines. I haven't talked about state machines yet.
This view is broken, so I'm not gonna
click into it. But what state machines do
is they orchestrate state transitions. Right? So it's
a it is like the literal, you know,
computer science definition of a of a state
machine. Right? It's got states and transitions.
But what Guidepad can do is it can
use your state machine. I'll actually show you
this, like, in code form because I have
it there, when we we hop out of
this view and into a different one.
But the state machines are can be set
into autonomous mode. That's this little toggle here.
And when I do that, there's that service
called the orchestrator
that manages the state transitions for the state
machine and then uses the state plans autonomously
to move the the service that's attached to
the state machine from state to state when
the requirement conditions are are met.
And, David, we actually that's the thing that
we did for the, the s three bucket,
that we were managing autonomously.
So, like, enforcing that the permissions were set
properly.
If someone deleted it, it recreated it.
Yeah. So that was using state machine concept,
in that in that orchestrate, Barry, that I
that I mentioned.
Which is for anyone who hasn't seen the
previous videos. We've done a couple of cool
things with Guidepad to date to show the
kind of benefits
and power behind the platform. One of them
was we built an s three reconciler that
made sure that an s three state, like,
IAC, was always reconciled to the correct state.
Even if it was deleted, that was recreating
stuff. That was very cool. People should go
check out that video, and I'll put a
link to it after the the livestream.
And the other thing that we have built
before was the URL shortener was some generative
AI summarizing of the HTML components as well.
Yep. You can do a lot with Guidepad.
And you've kind of touched on a lot
of the primitives that are exposed to people.
Right. And then the way that you connect
these together with Guidepad that kinda
makes them kick in and and do the
thing that you need to do. So yeah.
Right. That's that's sort of the magic is
is,
you know, we we there's been a term
that sort of come into vogue recently, which
is like compositional systems and compositional software.
I think Guidepad
is sort of, just by its very nature,
like a system like that. Right? Because you
have these primitive entities.
You can extend them.
You can customize them.
And then you can put them together to
make basically anything that you want to make.
And I think maybe that's a good segue
into
talking about the architecture of the thing that
I wanna build
on the stream unless you have another question
or anything before I before I do that.
No. Take it away. That's great. Perfect. Okay.
So
what we're gonna do is we're going to
try to
build
an AWS Lambda replacement for node.
So the ability to run node code
serverlessly
through the Guidepad framework.
And so if we think about what
if we think about what Lambda is doing,
right, so you've got, AWS up here,
and then you've got,
you know, your Lambda function.
So this Lambda
function,
and that's a colon that should not be
in there.
So get your lambda function,
that, like, executes
I don't know. There's some black box. Right?
There's some containerized
black box over here
that they run
your function in because, know, you can attach
a particular, like, image to it.
So you need a Docker image that contains
contains the,
you know, your code
artifacts and all the requirements. That's, you know,
if you wanna use any packages that aren't
contained within Lambda's default runtime.
So then, you know, and then out here,
you maybe have a,
I don't know. Think they released a thing
back in 2022,
which is like, you know, Lambda URLs.
Right?
So you can have like a Lambda URL
in front of it.
And then you've got your little client over
here.
Let's find a
nice icon for
a client.
You know what? I hate the mirror changes.
Let me just find client.
No. You're not gonna help me out. Alright.
Fine. Whatever. I'll just use,
this again.
Okay. So you have your client here. Right?
And it's gonna send the requests,
to the Lambda URL.
I don't know why I made that so
big. Let's make that smaller.
Thank you.
So it's gonna send that over there.
And then Lambda URL is, you know, attached
to your thing and this is gonna use
your Docker image
to,
you know, start the thing in the black
box. And then when the black box is
done, it's like, oh, hey, here's the result.
So it's gonna go back to the client.
So, we're gonna try to build something like
this in Guidepad.
And what does that look like as far
as, like, Guidepad components?
So, what we're gonna do is
we will have our environment.
And I'm gonna draw that with a
dotted line. Alright? So this is our Guidepad
environment.
What's called the Rawkode
KDS environment?
So, we got this thing here.
And then inside there,
what we need to do is we have
to have some
we have to have two things. Right? We
have to have something to represent the code
that we wanna execute,
and we need to have a place to
execute it.
So the place that we're gonna execute it
is what we call a language executor.
Let me just draw one of those.
And full disclosure, I kinda already have this
for Python,
but we have a full stack engineer on
the team who isn't super well versed in
Python and would rather write stuff in JavaScript.
And so I'm trying to be nice to
him, and, you know, give him a way
to write the
operations in the way that he would wanna
write them.
Yeah. Okay. So,
I
got that.
It's a solid. And so this is gonna
be our node
I
don't know how that happened. Node JS language
exec Nobody can type when they're being watched.
It's just like an unwritten swear to I
swear. Like, my my TPM
oh, no. Yeah. My words per minute go
down to, like, 60.
Right? When, like, when I'm I'm being observed.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's Schrodinger's words per minute. Right? Like,
they're they're incredibly fast as long as no
one is looking at me. Okay. Yeah.
Okay. So
we have language executor,
and then the other part we need to
have is the operation.
Right? So we need a Node. Js operation.
And this Node. Js operation is going to
contain a couple things.
So, actually, let me let me delete this
internal label and I'll make it a little
bigger
so that I can put some stuff inside
it.
And and the stuff I'm putting inside it
are gonna be they're, like, represented by database
references, so they're not literally contained within
this object.
And I should say that these are objects.
Right? Like, in in a database somewhere. Right?
Like, we're gonna have a language executor
record that exists somewhere,
and then we're gonna have an operation,
that also exists.
So
we're gonna have the language
or sorry. We're gonna have the Node. Js.
Js
operation.
Right?
And within that operation, we're gonna have a
couple things.
We're gonna have the input type.
We're gonna have the
output type.
And we're going to have the,
the implementation,
basically.
Right?
So let me make this a little bigger.
This a little bigger.
Because I have to draw some other things.
K.
And Miro recently changed yeah. It recently changed
the thing where if you drag the highlight,
it also highlights the thing in the background.
So I can't just, like, select.
It's it's so annoying.
Anyway, so we've got this stuff here. The
implementation is interesting because in order to store
it right? So if you think about the
implementation, right, that's just a handler.
It's the code. But in order for it
to be portable, it needs to be stored
somewhere.
So what we do in Guidepad is we
have this notion of an artifact,
which is stored in what we you know,
I hate saying we call it because it's
such like a simple word of like, of
course, you would call it this, but we
have what we labeled storage back end.
And a storage back end is just an
abstraction layer on top of different, like, storage
things for file like stuff.
So for for data like stuff, things that
are either structured or semi structured, have types
and data stores.
For things that are unstructured,
we just like file blobs. Right? Those are
artifacts and those go in storage back ends.
So for
the implementation,
what we're gonna do is we're gonna store
that
in an artifact. Right? So we're gonna have
an implementation
artifact.
And this is gonna contain the code
of our little Node. Js execution.
Full disclosure, it'll probably be like console dot
log something, just to make things not not
that complicated.
But we can get more complicated later,
just just a proof of concept. Right? You're
gonna walk first, or crawl first and then
walk.
So you got that.
The other thing that might be obvious to
folks, like an obvious question, right, is like
you have this operation,
you have the executor, like this thing is
supposed to run the function. Like, does it
how does it do that? Right? Like, how
do you get from from here to to
here?
Well, the way we do that in Guidepad
is we have this idea of a service
exposure.
So service exposure typically sits on the boundary
of a environment.
Right?
Sorry.
I can close this. Right? Yes. Thank you.
Okay. Perfect. Yeah. You can just click paid
on that if you mock that. Oh, this
too. Perfect. Okay. Thank you. I wasn't sure
if that showed up to the viewers or
not,
but
I'm glad that I I had it. So,
anyway, so typically a surface exposure sits here,
like, this boundary. Right? And it allows traffic
into,
a particular,
service on a particular protocol.
And so Guidepad supports a couple different protocols,
the usual ones. Right? HTTP, HTTPS,
TCP, UDP.
You can make service exposures through all that
stuff and then point them at your services.
And then the environment that you're living that
that thing is living in is managed by
Guidepad will expose it in the way that
you want it to. Think of if you
think about, like,
the Kubernetes service concept, that's what this is
except one level up. Right? So it's not
just Does your exposure map to the executor,
or does it map to
something else first? It seems a bit weird
that it goes straight to an executor. Right?
Well,
so the way that it it does go
straight to an executor.
Because in the service exposure, what we have
is a reference to the exposed service
within the record. Right? And so that just
points right to it.
And then it's the job of the environment's
public interface, which is another entity,
to take the service exposure and then manipulate
the environment in the way that it needs
to to make sure traffic can be routed
properly.
But that's not what we're gonna use it
for here. What we're gonna do is link
the operation
to the service exposure.
Right? So Guidepad has the ability to say
this
operation is actually handled by
the service pointed to by the service exposure.
So when you call execute,
you don't hand like, because a node a
default operation in Guidepad has an execute method
attached to it. And that runs normally, takes
the input, calls the handler, produces the output,
and returns it to the caller.
When you link a an operation to a
service exposure,
it tries to see if Guidepad
knows the protocol of the service exposure and
then will opt then will handle the operation
over that protocol rather than call the internal
execute method.
And so that's what we're gonna do here.
Right? So that it,
you know, so so when this thing is
called, it's gonna be like, oh, hey. I'm,
like, actually linked to the service exposure which
is linked to this Node. Js executor.
I'm gonna send my request over there,
run, and then return the results.
And what it also does is sort of
shunts this
into here so that it can run.
Right? Like at run time. Like,
you know, transfer.
Right? So
say calls
and then calls
and then I guess this thing, yeah, this
thing uses that. So anyway, so this is
what we're gonna do, right, in order to
get it to to work. Does that make
sense or any questions or
things I should clarify?
Potentially.
Okay.
No. I think I think I'm definitely following
along. Right? We're
I I we're trying to repeat it back,
and you can tell me anything that I
get wrong. Sure. And we'll see where we
are. So
let's start with the easy part here. The
service exposure is some sort of domain name,
port mapping,
ingress to our environment.
Just a thing. Right? It could be Rawkode.ishere.com,
and then comes into the service exposure. That
service exposure has a direct link or relationship
with a Node. Js operation,
and that is all bundled together for the
executor to know what to execute, I'm assuming,
where the implementation is coming from artifact storage,
which could be, let's just say, SC compatible
API or something like that.
And then the executor takes all of that
information, the service exposure, the operation, and the
artifact
executes
the thing
and then returns our response. That's kind of
my understanding at the moment. I don't know
if I got any of that wrong. Yeah.
You got most of it. The only thing
is that it's the actual operation that handles
all of that negotiation
stuff,
and the executor is just dumb. Right? It
literally just takes a command.
So it's a it's a pretty stupid service.
I'll I'll show you I'll show you its
implementation.
But yeah. So that's that's the idea. Right?
I think you got it. Is Well, let
me ask you a couple more questions then.
Of course. Because, obviously, right now, are watching.
They get a
pretty deep insight into how Guidepad works.
Now we're doing this for Node. Js. You
mentioned the Python exists. But one of the
things that we have discussed before is that
Guidepad can make this work for any language.
I mean, it could be Go. It could
be Elixir. I'm assuming it could even be
a bash shell script. It's not really that
opinionated. If you can write an executor,
then Guidepad can do it. Right? Yep.
So, I mean And it's very small. I'll
show you the executor.
Yeah. Let's take a look. Let's go for
it.
There it is.
We only see.
Oh, no.
There you go.
I did it for suspense.
Here. Here it is.
Alright.
So
there's an attribute called service type. There's a
deep copy.
Where does it execute?
Yeah. That's a good question.
So
remember we have this operation. Right? Yes. Like,
this is the thing that actually does the
operating.
The service is just so you can have
something deployed that can handle the operation request.
Right? So that's why it's so small, is
it's just like, I need to have a
service that I can basically attach an an
image to so that when I deploy it,
the right image gets deployed.
And that's what the service is doing.
The operation I'll show you the operation,
and that is not in the plug oh,
sorry. I showed you a plug in and
I didn't mention plug ins.
So let me let me
do a quick aside on the plugin and
tell you what that is. So,
you can see this is a a repository.
Right? It's called Guidepad demo.
So Guidepad has the notion of plugins, and
plugins allow you to layer functionality on top
of the core system. And then what we
typically do with plug ins is that we'll
have one per sort of, like, industry vertical
that we run into.
So for example, we we have a services
division at at the company,
and we're doing something for, an emergency transport
company. They want us to make a, like,
a ride sharing thing.
And so what we did is we wrote
a plug in for
ride sharing on top of Guidepad, and then
we wrote another plug in on top of
that that is just for this particular customer.
Right? So we've specialized Guidepad in this in
their instance for transport related concepts,
and then we made more customizations just for
that particular customer. And then if we had
other customers in that vertical, we would customize
again.
But what I'm doing here with this demo
and every plugin is a repository. Right? It's
in Python at the moment, but, you know,
we have plans for SDKs,
for all the, you know, all the sort
of popular stuff.
It's in the road map. We'll see when
we get there.
But, anyway, so, you know, this is sort
of the structure of of a plugin. Right?
You have, like, the top level sub package.
You have a little entry point here called
plugin dot py.
This is sort of where everything gets exported
from your plugin,
And then you define, like, custom operations, custom
services,
like this
demo JS executor.
You can do custom types, which we actually
haven't talked about too much, we will. I
I promise. We'll get we'll get to everything.
And then work plans, if you wanna have
custom work plans.
And then at runtime, what Guidepad does is
it reads the plug ins that are configured
in your instance,
of reconciles if there are changes in the
remote that you don't have locally. If it
does, there are changes that pulls them,
installs all the requirements, and then adds everything
in the plug in to your runtime
environment so you have access to all this
all this stuff.
And so what we're doing with the, the
demo JS executor
is we're override we're extending
a,
service that comes from Vanilla Guidepad, right, here
at the language executor,
which is that's that's the the thing that
you were talking about, just a moment ago,
David, about, you know, if we wanna do
this for another language,
right, like, do you what would you need
to do?
Well, you would, you know, extend
this executor,
and then you would also,
go into I I don't have this in
the plugin yet. It's just a normal Guidepad.
But you would go and also extend the
operation.
Sorry.
Here. So
this is the language exec operation.
Right?
And we wanna know JS
one of that of this, basically. Right? So
Yeah. Luckily, I've already written it. You can
see it's also very small.
Okay. So now it's starting to click for
me. I didn't when you showed me the
class at first, I didn't realize the state
machine was above it where it's kinda defining
that it's gonna run inside the container.
Now we can see the command is no
word followed by the file name. Whatever.
So now it's starting to come together about
how this actually works. Can we take a
look at that state plan and the the
plugin?
Oh, yeah. Sure.
The The state machine. Sorry. Yeah. That's fine.
It's it doesn't work yet. So this is
this is gonna be part of the
maybe the advanced
session after this one, is getting this to
work because I thought This isn't the advanced
one because my brain is already fried. Come
on. Oh, no. Oh, no. I've I need
to slow down.
This is supposed to be yeah. This is
supposed to be like Guidepad, maybe maybe 102.
I I didn't realize I was giving, 602.
So I can I can maybe
tone it down a couple notches?
But anyway,
yeah. So this is this is the state
machine that that I wanna use to eventually
manage the executor.
Right? Because, like, if you think about
Lambda,
when you run a Lambda function, you don't
have to tell Lambda, like, hey. I'm about
to run my function. I also have to
go manually, like, deploy,
you know, the runtime for that function is
going to to execute.
So we'd want the same thing in our
Guidepad replacement. Right? And how would how would
you do that in Guidepad? Well, you would
do it with a state machine.
And what that state machine would do, I've
I've sort of started to to put it
in here, but I haven't I haven't fully
flushed it out yet.
You would use Guidepad's requirements system
to say, if there is
an operation that's trying to run, but it
can't, so it's in the pending state,
I need to take this service and rebuild
it and then redeploy it.
Yep. Right? And so that's what I'm hoping
to encode here in the state machine,
for each of these. So I have the
transitions built up. Right? So I I have
a a transition from not deployed to built.
Right? So this thing doesn't exist anywhere yet,
but you need to go build it.
And then the next thing is, oh, I
wanna be able to go from deployed to
not deployed. So after
maybe some cool down period, no one's used
the operation in a while, I'm gonna undeploy
the service to free up resources in my
cluster.
And then this one here is,
I'm gonna take this from deployed to built.
So this is the thing's already out there.
Someone has updated the configuration for my executor
to require additional packages.
So, you know, I've I've updated my handler.
I now use x y z package in
my little node script or whatever.
The thing's already out there. I'm gonna rebuild
it to include that package, and then I'm
gonna redeploy it right after.
And
then this one just goes from built to
deployed. So this is like, build's finished. I'm
gonna go deploy it.
Yeah.
But they're not wired up to all the
requirements yet, I can't actually use it.
But it at least it sort of lays
out conceptually,
this is you know? And if and if
the UI was working, you'd be able to
see these states, like, logically, sort of, like,
mapped out. Right? Like, these are all the
valid states for this type of service. This
is how it moves between them.
All that's missing are the conditions
for the transitions.
So Alright.
Okay.
More questions?
Here's the state plan. I'm fully up to
speed there. So Okay. Okay. Here's the state
plan. Right? So this is the actual commands
that happen as we move from phase to
phase. Right? Yeah. Yeah. So this is it
uses all the default ones, so that's what's
happening down here. I'm just pulling in the
defaults from,
you know, Vanilla Guidepad. I'm customizing the build
state plan here,
And
I'm adding build commands.
And you could put them in line. Like,
you put you could just put them in
the same module.
Right? But in order to do that, have
to kinda do something like this.
You know? And then
I don't really like doing that.
So what I tend to do is put
them in a file sort of next to
the service.
Yeah. That means And then
validate. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
So we can look at that.
Is this?
Of course, I've broken the syntax highlighting. I
did that after I wrote it the first
time.
But
I'm using templating, right, to only do this
when they're when certain things are defined. So
this uses like Guidepads.
It's using Ginger two under the hood, which
sort of everybody does if you're doing string
interpolation.
Right?
Maybe we'll write our own one day if
we ever ever make it big. But anyway,
so we just have custom block opens. Right?
So that if you're writing something in Ansible
or something else uses Jinja, there's no conflicts
there.
Because if you use the standard ones, it'll
just replace all your stuff or make you
write, you know,
curly bracket,
percent raw and then that. And then that's
also very annoying, so didn't, you know, didn't
wanna have to do that. But, anyway, what
this is doing is,
if there are any system package requirements defined
on your service or anywhere in the context
that the service is execute like, is in
when it enters that state,
it will install them here, which uses APK,
because we're using an output the node alpine,
image as the the starting point.
And then down here,
it installs
basically,
if you have NPM requirements.
Yep. Yeah.
So,
yeah.
That's that's what that does.
Oh, sorry. Yeah. System package. So, yeah. So
so APK for system packages and then NPM
for any node modules that you need.
And we can we can add some of
these and rebuild
when we feel like it. But let's,
yeah, let's not do that just yet. Sorry.
I I was just peeking at the time.
Okay. So more questions or are we we
good to start doing things
in the terminal?
Yeah. Let's go for it. Okay.
So
sorry. Gotta stretch. I
always debate, like, whether I want to do
this stuff
in,
you know, in a notebook. I like working
in notebooks a lot,
Jupyter notebooks, just because
it's sort of repeatable.
I can just kill the kernel and, like,
rerun everything.
If I'm in IPython and I'm making a
bunch of changes,
it's a little harder to, like, do it.
So I'll probably do it in here today.
So
okay. Let's let's go back to, like, our
diagram real quick and just think through, like,
what we what we need. So we need
a Node. Js operation.
We need,
this implementation artifact attached to it. We need
the Node. Js language executor,
and we need the the service exposure.
So I've shown you the class for the
Node. Js language executor, but I haven't shown
you the, the instance of it yet. And
I actually made that already. I know that's
kinda kinda cheating,
but I did. So I apologize,
for that. But,
here, let's take a peek at your in
let's let's go under the hood, because I
showed you all, like, the deployed stuff, like,
in the, user interface, but, like, let's actually
use kubectl,
to, like, look at the stuff, like, in,
you know, in your in your instance.
So you probably don't remember this, but in
the user interface, the actually,
I'll just go over there and I'll show
you.
Sorry.
So if you go back to the environment,
we go to the settings.
So this just so your audience knows, like,
this form is auto generated.
So what it does is it reads the
type definition for whatever type of thing you're
looking at and then generates
the the wizard, basically, off that type definition.
We haven't talked about types at all, but
but types are our
language agnostic database representation for for schemas.
And so everything that we've looked at so
far is a type at the end of
the day, and that's how it's stored in
a database. We have a type for environment.
Right? And we have a type for Kubernetes
environment, which is what this actual type of
environment is.
So we go through, there's sort of like
the vanilla, like, stuff, but then you get
to here. Right? And you can see, like,
oh, there's a Rawkode namespace.
And that means that everything
and this is only on Kubernetes environment types.
Right? Like, other environments don't care about a
namespace, so why would they why would they
have that? And
so this namespace
is actually in the cluster. Right? So if
I do k a
this too small? Should I increase this or
is this looking good? No. I think we're
okay. Okay. Great.
Let's get all the pods.
Here they are.
You can see this is from my,
setup last night. You can see how old
this
you can see how old this, project is.
It's about a day old.
That's when the stuff was that's when the
stuff was put in here.
Anyway, so these are all the things that
have been deployed. Right? Like Guidepad is managing
all of these bots,
essentially,
as part of the the deployments.
And we actually already have
a little Node. Js executor
in here. Yep. We'll come back to that.
But I just wanted to sort of show
you, like, here's some stuff. It exists.
And now we'll go back into that notebook
I was looking at, and I'll show you
the data record for the
for that service.
And, you know, this is sort of the
standard way that, like, we interface with Guidepad,
like, in an in in an interactive session.
You typically don't have to do this. I'm
just doing this because I might make changes
to my local
code without I don't wanna have to push
it up every time, basically, so I'm sort
of cheating,
and just setting my Python path.
If I remove this,
when this happens, Guidepad will pull down that
repository for the demo plug in and put
it on my Python path for me. So
I don't have to do that. I'm just
I just want to.
So I'll do that. It's gonna initialize Guidepad,
and we'll use it for the rest of
the
session here.
It's starting a kernel, so it's taking an
extra second.
Okay. Cool. So I guess we can walk
through what what what just happens because this
is probably your audience's first time seeing it.
So we load the connection details from a
local environment.
Guidepad can be configured either with a direct
connection to the primary data store that I'm
using and that's like super admin access.
Or you can use it in, API proxy
mode where you just have and this is
what we do for,
like, end users at at our customers. Like,
you just give them their username and password
and they you can actually use Guidepad
through our API. So it translates all of
the data store requests into API requests,
and then uses the RBAC, like, for that
user to sort of sandbox all their permissions
and stuff.
But since I'm me, I don't have to
do that, and I can just connect directly.
So that's what I did. So, let's take
a look at that
Node. Js executor thing,
that we had just talked about. So I'm
gonna import the type registry.
Types dot registry. Import the type registry.
So, the type registry is an object inside
Guidepad that knows everything about all the types
in your instance.
And the nice thing about the type registry
is you can ask for any type you
want from it.
So you can just give it the type
name or the class name.
I'll just do the type name to show
that you can do that. And then if
I were to look at the
variables that are set up,
you can see here that this service that
I just assigned is a fully fledged class
that was generated by Guidepad from the definition
of what it means to be a service.
Like a service container from OOP.
Yes.
Yep.
Yep. So here we go. We get all
the attributes that are defined on a service,
all that good stuff. But the other thing
you can do with a type once you
have it, right, is you can do CRUD
operations
on it. So I wanna find the Node
JS service that I made earlier so that
we can play with it.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
say Node JS is service.listsingle.
And I don't remember what the name of
that thing is. Actually, let me just get
all of them and then
I'll just find it in the list because
I don't I'm getting I turned 40 this
year, so
short term memory is no longer one of
my my strong my strong suits.
Yeah. I hear that.
So I'm just gonna grab them all, and
then we can take a peek and figure
out which one I actually want.
Why
don't you why don't you refresh?
Oh, you know what? It's because I'm in
the wrong one. No. I'm not.
Oh, there it is. Yep. Great.
I guess it just took a second. So,
let the the the
let's see here.
You.
Perfect.
It's not coming back as the right service,
though, so that's a little troubling. Right? Like,
it should be coming back as the,
as, like, the class. Right? So you can
see the classes here, like, next to it.
Right?
Yep. And it should be coming back as
a Node JS,
like, executor service, but it's coming back as,
a bare service. So I need to figure
out, like, why
that is happening.
It might be
I'll just I'll just verify that.
So let's see. Node. Js is services minus
one,
and then Node. Js
Wasn't fast enough. Yeah. It's coming back as
a service. That's strange.
Well, it doesn't actually hurt us too much
as long as when we, like, do the
deployment and stuff, it's, like,
coming back to the right type.
But it's strange you know what? What usually
happens when this occurs is that Guidepad doesn't
have it doesn't know what that type of
thing is yet, and so it just returns
the default type. Right? So you can see
here,
it was able to find the
specific types for these, and so it returned
them. But, this is just a bare service.
And, you know, this one in particular,
that we're looking at now, like, can't find
the the subtype for it. So it just
returns, like, the the normal type so that
it doesn't, you know, completely throw up.
That's okay. We can we can still work
with this. So,
going back to our diagram, like, have this
service.
Right?
We have a service.
We need the operation,
and we need the implementation,
and we need a service exposure to to
point to it. So let's let's work on
those let's work on those pieces.
So let's pull in an operation.
So we said we wanna do a Node.
Js operation.
So we'll just import that real quick from
Guidepad dot operations built in language exec
Node. Js
Node. Js operation.
I could do this or I could do
I'm gonna make sure I capitalize it correctly.
As long as it's in Guidepad's
sort of like global context, it should come
back as the right thing. Yep.
Yep. We got it. There.
Oh, no. It's a string.
String. Yeah. Yeah. Boo. Okay. Here, let's fix
it.
So I think what happened is it's just
not in, the system,
like, scope. So what Guidepad does is when
it when it does the initialize,
it pulls all the types that have been
persisted to the data store and then also
it sort of merges that information with what
is defined, like, within the code.
So what that means that come came back
as a string is it's either not been
persisted into Guidepad's, like, centralized data storage
or it's not imported in the system level
packages the Guidepad maintains
to, like, make sure everything's in scope, like,
when when it starts up. So let let's
just make sure it's in scope, then I'll
refresh this, that should return
what I want it to return.
So we just have this thing, system types.
It's where everybody lives.
Very large.
So I'm guessing
yep.
Just gonna send it here.
And would that be why we got a
generic service type for the Node. J executor?
Probably.
And that one is a little
like, that shouldn't be important here because it's
defined in a plug in. Right? So the
plug in should be loading it for us.
But the reason the fact that it's not
and, actually, thank you. Just
talking through it, I now know why it's
not doing that.
It's because it didn't do this.
So I said there's a plugin entry point,
right, that, like, sort of exports everything that
the plug in defines, but I did not
I did not do that for my my
new my new shiny toy. So, that's why
it's not there.
And you can see I was I was
doing a dog walker demo before this. So,
that's why that stuff's in there. Let's
see.
Oh, it's demo node. Yes. Perfect. Okay. So
I'm gonna save that.
We're gonna save this over here once I
get
built in
language exec
node
node.
Perfect.
Okay.
So having done that, now I think I
can just, like, restart the kernel and rerun
all this good stuff, and then it should
come back the right way.
Yep.
Yeah. So everything's everything's happy. Right? Like, you
can find all the stuff now, and everything's
the right
everything's the right type of thing.
So what wanna do is wanna make an
instance of this operation.
Right?
And the Node. Js operation,
if you wanna know, like, what attributes it
takes, you can always find that defined on
the type itself.
Let's do keys.
And these are all the attributes.
If you do items instead,
it comes back names and
attribute types,
and they can introspect all the attribute types
to, like, find out what they are if
you want to.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna
make an instance of this of this operation.
Right?
And I believe all we need to do
is say my node j s op
is this,
and the name is gonna be a demo
Node JS
operation.
And let me just I'm just gonna verify
that, like, there aren't any,
Of course, it does that. Yeah.
I mean, it's very straightforward. There's, like, nothing
crazy I need to set in here.
Same thing at this level.
It's just this,
but that's actually set. Okay. Great.
So go back to here
and then that. And then
the only other keyword is exec support
provided by,
like, Citibank or,
I don't know,
Publix.
No. It's provided by the, the Node. Js,
executor that we
got up there.
So all this is doing is telling to
this operation that, hey, when
you try to execute,
if you don't see that there is one
of these types of things because remember this
is a type.
I should have, like, named it better. Oh,
no. Sorry. That's the service.
It's not the type. Let's get the type
instead.
And we call that demo demo JS executor.
That's right.
You gonna update for me?
Oh, yeah. Okay.
That's good.
Perfect.
So then we can put that in here,
and then do that.
And so now we have this operation. You
can inspect it down here below.
It's active. It doesn't run-in async mode. That's
okay.
I'll talk about async mode later if you
want to.
It's got a bunch of options for, like,
you know, things that happen in the API,
like batch, or you can disable authorization if
this is just like a bare,
thing that anybody can hit. By default, Guidepad
puts all the operations behind our back on
all of the APIs that it that it
uses.
And so there's a whole way to, like,
link operations
to roles and then roles to users, and
then that's how you can control access to
them.
Sorry. I'm just going I'm just going through
here, making sure we have everything we need.
Provided by is the thing that we wanna
set. Right? So this is a link. If
you look at the it's a reference collection.
And the
reference to it, if I go and and
show you the actual, like,
type for this, if I go
Node. Js
executor,
and then we wanna look at, provided by.
You can see
oh,
you know what? That's an operation.
Node. Js operation. There we go. Thanks. It's
a reference. What's what is it a reference
to?
Oh my god. Reference object.
Shush.
Why why do you like this?
Nope. It's a one to one.
My bad.
I'm just gonna go to the definition. It
should be there. It should be there.
Okay. Yeah. Reference type. I don't know why
it's being so You typed a you referenced.
Oh, did I type did I type a?
Yeah. There we go. Perfect. Okay.
So, yeah. So, you can see before, like,
in the diagram, right, like, we want to
link
this operation to a surface exposure. Well, how
are gonna do that? We're gonna do that
through the provided by attribute because it's a
reference to a surface exposure.
So the next thing we're gonna do is
we're going to import the service exposure type.
So, exposure.
And then, so we have this thing and
we wanna make a surface exposure. So, what
are we gonna do? We're going to say
s as a surface exposure.
And if I show you the surface exposure
class,
again, it's defined like, that's the interesting one
of the interesting things about Guidepad is, like,
you can define types in code. You can
define them strictly in data or you can
do a hybrid thing where some of it
is in code and then you, like, add
stuff on from data storage.
But for all of, like, the core Guidepad
types, we just implement them as code, like,
in, you know, in the library. Right? So
this is a service exposure here.
The things that we're interested in on this
are the exposed service, which we're gonna link
to the
executor that we created.
We're going to
not care about the public interface ID or
the suffix
or the ports, but we are gonna care
about the protocol. Right? Because that's the thing
that knows how to communicate with the Node.
Js executor that we
have on hand.
We wanna make sure it's active.
And the other stuff doesn't doesn't matter a
whole bunch. Great. So,
so we're gonna make one. We're gonna call
this the demo
demo node JS,
executor
exposure.
And the protocol
is
going to be
sorry.
Cube
exec
without a minus.
So,
this is not a standard protocol.
Right? Obviously.
This is a protocol that we came up
with so that our operations can talk to
a pod, basically, running in Kubernetes.
But what that means, though, is that any
service that you want to use this
particular protocol we implemented, you you can as
long as you have Guidepad.
So we're gonna do that. We're gonna say
the exposed service
is our Node. Js
service. Let me just make sure I haven't
overwritten that with anything. Nope. Still the right
service. Great.
And do that.
And so, now, these objects just exist in
memory. Right? Like, they're not persisted anywhere. Guidepad,
like, has no, like, notion of them.
They're just locally on my on my machine.
So what we need to do is we
need to save them so that they get
persistent to Guidepads, data storage, and that we
can use them in, like, downstream
stuff.
So,
we're gonna do Node. Js,
save,
and s save.
And there's a lot that goes on when
I do this, so I I don't wanna
I don't want to
What's that? Do you not need to save
the operation as well?
We will in a moment.
Haven't linked those things together yet,
so that's why I'm not saving them. I'm
just saving these two, for now.
So it's gonna take a minute because the
Node well, I should say that we're connected
to a, a very small MongoDB instance. Very
small, meaning an eighth of a CPU.
So the fact that it works for me
at all is wonderful.
Yeah. Anyway,
so those are saved now. So, if I
wanted to, like, fetch them, right, I I
could. I could just do,
you know, my Node. Js.
Oh, you know what? No. I don't know
why I saved Node. Js. Oh, you know
why I saved Node. Js? Yeah. Because now
it's exposed. I didn't need to do that.
I've already fetched this, but now I can
fetch the exposure if I wanted to. So,
it's s is service exposure.
So, I just wanna make sure that, like,
it's saved properly, you know, so it's service
exposure list.
And it's a special by name.
Oh, sorry. List single.
List list without
the single on it is for many things.
It returns a generator. I I just want
a single one. So you can see it
down here. This is the exposure we just
created.
You can see its name, its protocol, cubics
deck.
It's attached to the right
service.
We can see that if we go through
here and here.
And the name is that executor that we
have. So, now we have completed
this step and linked it to this.
Now, we need to make our operation complete,
and then,
we should be almost ready to actually, like,
run the operation.
Alright. So
and and, obviously, I'm I'm taking a little
bit longer than normal because I I wanna
make sure this all makes sense.
Yeah. I appreciate it. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So
you have the Node JS operation. We wanna
link it to the service exposure so that
it can handle the requests on our on
our behalf. So we just do Node JS
op
provided by
is
s.
Okay.
And then if I go to the Node
JS op,
we can now see that the provided by
is linked to that service exposure, so I
can go ahead and save it.
Okay.
Cool.
So does that service exposure have an endpoint
we can
curl? Like, how do we interact with that
service exposure now?
So you won't actually need to. Right? Because
because the thing you wanna op you wanna
interface with is your operation.
So this will have an endpoint.
This will not. Okay. Okay. Because I haven't
I haven't, like, actually attached this to a
public interface anywhere. So it's sort of just
like an internal exposure that Guidepad can use.
Alright. Okay. So the service exposure is for
the executor and then the operation is what's
alright. Okay. This is what everybody wants to
use. Right? You want this portable thing that
can run, yeah, some node code.
Yep.
Okay. So we got all those bits and
pieces. Let's pretend that I hadn't deployed
the,
the executor.
Right? So let's let's build it and then,
like, deploy it,
just so we can see the magic happen.
So what we wanna do is I'm gonna
use the CLI for this.
And I know, David, we talked about, like,
me working on
the the cool text
UI.
That's still something I'm working on, but I
haven't gotten there yet. So we're I was
gonna ask about that, but, you know No.
It's not ready. It's not ready for prime
time. Maybe I can preview it, but, yeah,
we we still have to deal with the
the multiple connects every time we run a
command, unfortunately.
At least in this I mean, that's that's
sort of why I work over here. Right?
So that you only have to do, like,
one initialize and you can go nuts.
Service enter state. So, we're gonna use Guidepad
CLI to have the service enter a particular
state. What state do you wanna have it
enter? You wanna have it enter the built
state because we need to build the image
that the
executor is gonna use when it runs.
So, I'm just gonna pull the,
sorry. I'm gonna pull the name from here
again so I don't have to, like, type
it.
Great.
Why'd you put floats around it? Okay. So,
you need the name of the service, you
need the name of the environment, that's just
Rawkode.
And then you need the name of the,
the state that you want it to go
into. So, if I hit enter,
it's gonna connect to Guidepad.
It's gonna look up all the state plans
that this service has.
It's going to look at the environment and
be like, state plans do you have that
are compatible with the environment that you selected?
Well, there's this one. It is the build
Node. Js docker image,
and it will put it in the build
state. Do I wanna proceed?
Absolutely.
So I'm gonna hit yes,
and then it's gonna wait a tick. So
you can see it's actually, like, running the
state plan here.
Cool?
Nice.
That did not look right, though. That
was way too fast. That was way too
fast to build an image.
So I'm guessing something happened and I have
a good idea of what went wrong.
Is that somehow the state plan for deploy
has the build state attached to it. So
this was actually the the deploy plan because
you can see
yeah. It just, like, did something super super
fast. So
let's take a look.
We can peek under the hood
and see what happened
because there would be something new in here.
I need to delete those. Why haven't I
deleted those yet? Yeah. See, like, nothing
like, nothing happened.
Right? So
something really funky
went on here.
So does that mean we have to look
at the state plan? It does. Yeah. It
means we need to to debug what's actually
happening here.
So you can see it's using this stage.
Yep.
Right?
Oh,
user error.
It's not that environment.
That environment is a Kubernetes cluster. So, of
course,
it's going to try to, like,
run these Ansible commands against Kubernetes.
I want the build environment,
not
the like, not the production environment. Right? I
need to build this image in Packer. So
I need to use a different environment
name.
We'll go back over here.
It's this one.
Packer build.
Yes.
Guidepad default build. So, we're gonna do that
instead.
It's gonna do the connection stuff. It's gonna
ask me again.
I'm gonna hit yes.
Okay. Great. We're not seeing Ansible, which is
a great sign
because that means it's doing something
funkier,
which I'm very I'm both proud of and
not proud of what it's doing right now.
So,
here, what it's doing is this.
It's
gonna be making a pod over here in
a second.
I hope so. I sure hope so. Let's
check out the
let's check out the manager and see what
it's doing. Would it be in a different
namespace?
It shouldn't.
It should know better than that.
That's not that's not how I brought it
up. Oh, yeah. See, it's it's going now.
So, it should be it should be appearing
momentarily.
Yes. Perfect. Okay. So, it's here. Seconds ago.
Cool.
Okay. So, what happened there is
Guidepad
ran a state plan. It said, hey, I
wanna run the state plan against the Guidepad
build environment.
The Guidepad build environment has what we like,
each environment has what we call a control
plane, and that's the thing that takes the
state plan instructions and, like, executes it against
that environment type.
For the packer build environment, there is a
packer
control plane.
And what that does is it actually uses
Guidepad's work plan management system
to schedule a pod that knows how to
build the thing using the instructions in the
state plan.
So that's what's happening here. Right? Like, we're
using our internal automation tool to automatically run
and manage a build of an image using
Docker and Docker. Like, they have to use
Docker and Docker image to do that,
which is its own can of worms. But
we we take care of that can of
worms for you, so you don't have to
do that.
And then if you look at the logs,
you can probably see what packer's been up
to.
Unless I have debugging turned off, I might.
Yep. All done.
So this built a new image, and if
I go over the other thing,
you can see that it it said it
was successful. Right? So now we've we've built
an image,
for this,
for the service. And if I wanna look
at that image
remember, have the notion of artifacts. Right? So
artifacts are things that are file like.
Well, we considered Docker images to be file
like objects, so we put them in our
in our artifact storage.
So if we were to take the artifact
type
and get all my artifacts
you know what? Let me yeah. I'll I'll
just do a filter on it. Okay. Artifacts,
docker images.
Nope.
Right in the middle. Yep. List.
The generator. I have to, like, make it
real.
Perfect. So, you see there's three in there.
Right?
There is the default image for Guidepad's
API. There is the default image for the
user interface.
And then there is this one. And this
one is the
artifact
that was built
for the demo JS executor.
Right? Alright. And you can see it was
last uploaded
just now.
It's in this storage back end, which is
the
Uh-oh. Sorry. It doesn't have a storage back
end because
I'll I'll spare you the gory details. We
can see this is where this is where
it lives.
Right? It's in our UCR.
Yep. So,
having built the image, right, like, we can
deploy it. So now I wanna do I
want I do wanna use that other environment.
I wanna go into the deployed state.
So this is what we saw earlier,
and that was why it was so sort
of concerning for me Yeah. Because now it's
deploying the thing. So if we go back
into the into the cluster,
you can see the old one's terminating
Yep. Down there.
And we'll just let it come back up.
And then I'll just show you that it's,
like, using the right image just as, a
a sanity check. Right? And then we can
also see that it's node because that was
the idea. Right? That we built a, like,
a node image, right, like, the fly. So
I should be able to get in there
and run the node binary.
So we'll do that too.
Are you serious? Yeah. I'm so
oh my god.
I swear I'm confident. I promise. I promise.
Sorry. You've had to do a lot of
typing in front of a camera, which is
never an easy task.
Well,
that's very generous of you to say. I
I I appreciate that.
Okay. So let's just, like, make sure it's
not doing anything because I'm pretty sure it
just sleeps when it starts up.
So, yeah, nothing going on. Great. Let's describe
it.
You can see here oh, let's look down
here at the bottom. Yep. So, here's that
image we made. Yep.
Great.
And if I get into it,
does it have node?
No.
Wonderful. Maybe it's gonna maybe, maybe,
node?
Nope.
Okay.
Well, which image was it made off of?
That would be good to know. Okay. So
here's what we're gonna do. We're going to
run the operation that built this thing locally
so that we can watch it happen, and
then it's going to tell us which image
it used as the source. So maybe what's
happening is that it's using a different image
that I'm trying to tell it to use.
Actually,
I know that's what's happening because right before
this call, I fixed the bug and I
did not push
the
bug fix. You get push and fix these.
You shouldn't. Yeah.
I know.
I know. Well, the thing is I I
haven't set up a CICD pipeline for you
yet,
because your thing's only a day old. And
I I don't know. I
quote unquote grew up before a lot of
the the modern, like, CICD stuff. So when
I'm doing things myself, I like to have
a manual touch sometimes.
But
this this is my fault. I I will
I will own this,
this this problem and we'll fix it. So,
what happened is the thing,
built the wrong image. Right? And it's because
in the version of the code that your
instance is using,
it doesn't respect the requirements that I'm putting
on the stage entity. So you can say,
hey, stage, when you are run, I want
you to use this requirement. So what I
did is I used that harness,
to attach an image requirement
to
the build process so that it uses the
node the node image.
But the code that you have in your
instance isn't respecting that. Right? So I'll just
run it locally,
and then we should be be good to
go.
So the way I'm gonna do that is
I'm actually gonna take the, operation.
So if you remember,
this thing
that ran oh, this isn't the one that's
gone. But it was running an operation asynchronously.
Right? So it was running a particular, like,
build operation.
I can take the build operation instructions from
this pod
and then just run them locally using Guidepad.
It'll run the same operation locally using the
code that I have.
So I'm gonna do that.
I'm just gonna pull this over here so
that you don't see some stuff
that you're not supposed to see
as far as credentials and things because I
can't guarantee this pod doesn't have them in
it.
Give me just a moment.
Yeah. Of course.
K. Great.
Okay.
Yeah. We're gonna have to maybe,
scrub some stuff out of this later.
If you wanna make a note of the
timestamp.
I think I was.
Okay. Thanks.
So,
I thought I'd be able to make it
the whole the whole call without doing it.
And I I almost got there.
Almost got there. Anyway, so this is the
operation that the
that the work plan was running. Right? So
I can run it locally myself just by,
like, grabbing the,
the stuff. So I'm gonna do that now.
And I'll put it in log level debug
so we can see it do the right
thing.
So you can see it's actually, like, using
packer, right, to build the image.
And here, it's using node, which is what
we
wanted to do
up at the up at the top here.
And that's gonna do the push and all
that good stuff.
Alright. And we're good. So, now we're gonna
redeploy the service.
And it should use the right image and
I should be able to run node
on it.
Cool. Okay. So let's try that again. Get
pods.
Let's wait for that to come back up.
Just add a get dash w to your
command. Oh, thank you.
Thanks. And we'll just wait for it to
You can see how much I'm usually, like,
in another thing and not not in here.
Appreciate that.
Germany, and there we go.
Awesome.
K.
Right image.
Move a trif. Yay.
Excellent.
Okay. Great. So we have the executor out
there. It's it exists.
Control d. Thank you.
Okay. So exists.
We can now
because we have the
let's go back to our our diagram. Right?
We've got the operation.
We've got the surface exposure. We've got the
Node. Js executor deployed using a node image.
We don't have this.
So let's make that, and then we can
probably try to run the operation and then
debug its inevitable failure,
for the rest of the for the rest
of the call.
So
where do wanna do that? Me go back
over here.
We have the class.
I'm pretty sure. Yep. We have the Node.
Js operation type,
and we have the op itself.
So one thing that operations have is sort
of a, like, a helper. Right? If I
go to the operation
class,
is it had they all have this method
on them,
which is
register implementation.
And they also have register text implementation.
And those two those those two methods take
care of all the legwork of creating that
artifact that I was referencing in the,
diagram.
So because we have an operation instance, I
can just call this method on it
and provide it some text,
and a like a dumb like a dummy
function name and a dummy file name,
and then it's gonna go make the artifact,
and then we should be able to call
the operation.
Okay.
So, we'll do Node. Js op.
Actually sorry.
Command.
Yeah. We're just gonna do console. Log.
Yeah.
And then we're gonna say Node. Js
Node. Js op
register
text implementation
command.
And then the function name is gonna be
hello,
and the file name is going to be
hello dot j s.
And I don't think I need to provide
a storage back end
because it should just use the default one
configured in the system.
Let's test out that assumption, though, and hit
enter.
Hey, there you go. So now we have
an artifact,
that
should contain that,
our little function in it, basically.
So now the moment of truth. Right? So
we have the operation.
We could just call it and then see
what explodes.
So I think we should do that.
Some confidence.
I like
to I like to set my ex. I'm
never disappointed. Right? Because Moe is like, it's
gonna be a disaster.
And then if it works, great. If not,
I assumed it was gonna be a disaster.
So yeah.
Anyway,
here, let's hit go.
Nope.
Didn't like it. Okay. So
let's reconfigure some things
and get it to go.
Messaging environment?
I do need to make a public interface.
Right. That's that's the part that is is
missing. So,
I was wrong in my diagram.
You do have to map this to a
public interface.
And it needs to be the public interface
for your environment that you're in. Right? So,
we're gonna have a k eight s
public interface
here.
And the reason we need to do that
is that this
operation
and the service exposure need to know,
like, needs to be able to get at
how do I, like, actually run something on
this pod back here. The way that you
know how to do that is through your
kube config file.
Right? Because that contains, the service address and
your credentials and all that good stuff. And
we happen to have one attached to this
environment.
Because every time you create a Kubernetes environment
in Guidepad,
it creates a, you know, service account, attaches
the creds to it,
so that that service account can only manage
the stuff, like, in your the namespace attached
to that environment, basically.
Excuse me.
So,
yeah. So this is gonna be like this.
And what that does here is it, like,
gets credentials
and,
connection details.
Oops.
Okay.
Yeah. And let's, let's drag this down here
a little bit so you can, like, read
that.
Okay.
But it's, you know, it's this.
It's from this environment. So, we'll do that.
Great.
Okay.
Actually, this lives in here. This lives there.
Beautiful.
Alright. So, the only step we missed was
setting up the public interface on the service
exposure. It's just another attribute, so we can
do that pretty easily.
So, if I go through here and I
pull in let's go back to where we
made the service exposure.
You know what? Let me just, I'll just
do it down here.
Think it's still bound to s. Right? Yeah.
It is.
So I'm gonna
remove this. I'm gonna pull in the environment
real quick.
So,
environment.
And then
code.
Good. Good.
You can see it's a Kubernetes environment, so
it should have all the stuff that we
need. It should also have a public interface
attached to it, so let's just double check
that really quick.
Here we go. Yep. Public interface. So, what
we're gonna do is we're gonna take that
public interface, we're gonna link it to the
service exposure so that that
function I just ran will work. So, we've
got s,
then we have public interface ID.
I'm gonna say Rawkode public interface
first
ID.
And I'll just double check that it is
still down to s.
It is. Perfect.
And then we'll do s dot save.
The nice thing about you doing this is
the Jupyter Notebook is now you've got everything
saved as a re artifact of how you've
done it. Exactly. And I can show this
to people on my team. I can give
it to other folks. I can revisit this
when someone's like, how did you do that?
Yeah.
And we try to, as much as possible,
like, encourage our team to to do this.
I mean, that when we we have a
machine learning engineer write a bunch of blog
posts and he would just do all his
work here. Right? And then put the markdown
for the blog post, like, in line with
it. Mhmm. It's very, very convenient.
So yeah. Okay. So we have everything linked
up. That particular error shouldn't happen anymore. Let's
call the operation again,
and let's actually, like, save the result
too. Okay.
Okay.
I'm gonna be like that. I get it.
Public interface, surface exposure, public interface ID.
That's not right.
So the surface exposure should have that set.
Yep. And it should be doing that there.
So, let me just make sure. Maybe it
didn't get set properly.
No. That's set.
And if I look
for the public interface,
Gosh. Sorry.
Interface.
I just wanna make sure, like, I can
find it myself.
Oh, and of course, it's gone now.
One thing I don't like about it is
that the copy key bindings, like, don't work
for stuff like in here. So, you have
to select
and then, like, copy and then paste.
Kind of annoying.
Okay. So we can find it when it
does it here,
and it's set properly on s.
Maybe
maybe it
didn't
take.
So let's pull it back out.
Let's inspect it.
Nope. It's there.
So we need do, like, some more digging.
Right? We need to, like, figure out where
somewhere in this
somewhere in this call chain, it's, like, not
getting the
public interface ID.
Okay. So let's go to the trace back.
It's here in
kube exec.
So this is the custom protocol implementation
for the KubeExec protocol that we did.
That's the whole backbone of this particular, like,
running stuff against a something deployed in Kubernetes.
So if we go to KubeExec
protocol,
we can see it's on
line 93,
which is right here.
No.
Not there.
I see. It's calling handle, cube exact exposure,
and then it's actually in handle cube mic.
Okay. Got it.
Yeah. Okay.
Public interface first. Oh,
okay. Well, it's saying you can't find that.
You know, keep this exposure.
Usages.
Okay. And so that happens in the operation.
Yep.
Sorry. I'm not sure if this is interesting
or not.
I'm just, so this is this is sort
of how you're getting to see how the
magic happens. Right? So,
when I call this operation,
right, like, when I do
this,
I'm basically doing the call,
like,
I'm I'm executing underscore underscore call on an
operation,
like, instance. Right? It's an instance of the
operation class. And so,
inside the operation,
there's an execute,
an execute method,
here.
And you can see this is another interesting
tidbit. It usually emits an event every time
it runs.
And so this helps us be a little
bit event driven. This is how we can,
like, wire things up to, like, when stuff
happens. Because you can set a requirement on
things, like your work plans and your state
plans that are conditional on a particular event
happening.
So those events could include,
like, an arbitrary operation firing,
right, or returning with a success or with
a failure,
or those things. And we we might see
that if we have another session where we
go into some other details.
But, anyway,
when you try to do execute though,
up in here,
it will do a couple things to figure
out like, oh, hey. Like, are you asynchronous?
Yes? No? Oh, I'm not asynchronous. I'm just
gonna do execute.
And then inside execute,
what's gonna happen is it tries to find
the implementation,
and the implementation,
could be one of three things. Right? It
could be either,
a surface exposure, which is what we're doing.
Right?
Or it could be,
handled in some remote artifact and you download
it and then compile the artifact and then
run it in the artifact or run it
from the artifact or you're just running a
local handler, which is what happens down here.
So we're up in the first case, right,
which is
we need to we're trying to execute this
operation through a service exposure, so we build
a partial function and return that.
And then we attach the target service exposure
as the first thing.
So the issue is you can see it's
trying to use provided by first,
and
what we've done is we've saved the public
interface on the service exposure,
but we haven't refreshed
the database definition of the operation.
Right. Right? So the operation is stale, and
so its service exposure pointer doesn't have the
public interface ID that we just set.
So one way to solve this within Guidepad
would be to have something like an instance
map where at the process level, we have
a map of all the objects that are
sort of in scope,
and then operations on one of them would
change it for everything that has a reference
to it. I haven't implemented that yet, but
it's on my sort of, like, internal mat
road map to do that one day.
Anyway, so what what that means we have
to do is just, like, we just have
to reload the we can either reload the
operation,
which will fetch the proper
which will fetch the proper,
service exposure details from the database or I
could just, like, reassign it.
We'll we'll do the former,
and just fetch it again from the database.
So
or fetch it for the first time because
we never we never fetched it after
creating it. So, let's do that.
So, we'll do that here.
You know what? Let me insert.
I know there's an insert above. I think
it's a right click operation. Yep.
No.
Fair enough.
Can I drag you?
You can also see, like, I I don't
do this too much either.
So let's cut let's cut you, paste you,
and then we're going to take this guy,
and we're going to fetch it again.
Yeah. Perfect. Okay.
So
that's
done here.
And then we're gonna do a list single
instead of this creation.
I know I didn't need to do that,
but whatever.
Good. Good. Good.
Okay. Great. And so let's take a peek
at that service exposure thing just to make
sure that it's
wired all wired up properly. Should be.
Provided by
provided by
First. Yep.
And then,
there we go. Good oof. Should be good
now. Okay. Let's do it again
and see where we get.
It's
it's doing stuff. Stuff that's happening.
Okay. It returned
and
What should I say? Oh, hey.
Hey. It works. Great.
So,
yeah. Okay.
So now you could put arbitrary
JavaScript
inside that operation.
Right? And it would run inside the executor
just by, like, reregistering
the
implementation.
You could also so, like, you know, here.
Right? Like, you could register a different handler.
Right? And then rerun it. So, like, let's
do it. You know? Let's do
hi
instead of hello.
It's not optimized, so it's not the fastest
thing in the world, but
Very nice. Yes.
So, yeah. Should I re go over sort
of, like, what's happening there? Or, like, what
do you what what are you interested in
in taking away from that?
I mean, I think I need a nap
after that. Okay.
Lucky I mean, I have to go back
to work, but I have a nap too.
No. I think
the way that you've walked through that really
helps solidify all the ideas. You know, I
think if people are watching this, right, and
you've stayed for nearly two hours to understand
how this works,
what they're gonna take away is everything is
a type. And I I love the way
that Jupyter notebook reveals that as well. You've
been pulling things out of the registry. You've
been using the methods for less less single,
even creating some resources.
All of this is just stored
as a as as like JSON, right, and
your your backing store and register Yeah. You
wanna see it?
This is you.
This is your this is your instance.
Yep. It's MongoDB.
But,
if we,
take a peek at this and I know
you said you needed an app, I apologize
for, like, dragging this on. But if I
do this, so from
Guidepad import datastore.
Right? And do datastore,
session datastores, datastores by name.
It's not just the one. Right? There's three
in play here. There's one that stores your
secrets encrypted at rest.
There's one that stores all that data. That's
what this is what we were just looking
at. Right? And then there's this one which
we haven't looked at, but it stores only
two types in there right now, log and
an event. Those two types go in there.
But that's all transparent. Right? So, like, if
I were to import the log type and
then do log dot list, it would go
out to that data store.
But you wouldn't know that. Right? Unless you
cared about it, in which case you wouldn't
know about it. But yeah. So this is
all
all of it stored in here. Right? All
of those things that we were fetching.
Same thing that showed on the user interface,
same thing that we interfaced with on the
on the command line.
Yeah. I I just think this is super
cool the way it's all the keywords is
what you said earlier. Right? It's composition.
And all these types come together to provide
a very
I don't wanna say a cohesive system. Right?
But, you know, whatever system you're trying to
build, you can architect those types to do
the things that you want. And there there's
so many things we could dive into. I
mean, even the event driven stuff with the
annotation on the function was really cool, but
I think what we need to do
is schedule a follow-up Sure. Where we can
dive into some of these concepts in more
detail,
build something else, and just keep showing people
the power of the Guidepad the Guidepad framework
because there's a lot to digest here.
So I'm gonna say let's leave it there
for now. Okay. And a follow-up scheduled. And,
hopefully, you know, if you've watched us, please
leave comments in the comment section. Let us
know what you want us to build, what
you want us to dive deeper into, and
we'll make sure that we have a follow-up
where we go into this in much more
detail.
I'm gonna pop over just to our big
face mode now so we can Sure. Cool.
Up.
Just because I I also wanna get home
to do my daughter's bedtime. So that Oh,
yeah. Makes sense.
But that was fantastic. Thank you so much,
Matthew. Like Thanks for having me. And thanks
for many times. But What's that? You can
I've said this so many times to you,
to Reggie, and and on previous videos. Right?
The things
it's really as limitless, the things you can
do with Guidepad. Like, your own imagination is
the only limitation.
And I hope what people take away from
that is just, like,
understanding those atomic types, the primitives, how you
can pose them together.
You really can build anything on this. So,
you know, go to Guidepad.io,
check out the website, and get in touch
with the team and,
yeah, make some awesome things together.
Well, yeah, thanks for thanks for having us.
It's been a been a pleasure. Thanks for
putting up with my
my mind. I mean, because Guidepad is is
like it's my brain. So thanks for thanks
for living inside it for two hours. I
appreciate that. Definitely my pleasure. Was a whole
lot of fun. Any
last words before we we say goodbye to
people?
Oh, I think I've said enough. But looking
forward to looking forward to the next thing
we get to do.
Yeah. I had fun. So, again Me too.
Thanks for having me. Yep. Alright. To everyone
watching, thank you for joining us. And remember
to get your comments into the comment section.
Matthew and I will definitely be following up
again soon. And, Matthew, thank you again for
walking us through that. I'll speak to you
shortly. To everyone else, have a great evening.
Take care.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.